canal mais je l' ai promis tiphaine
taillefer nous attend pour faire en
sorte que nous puissions apprendre à nos
enfants à découvrir par exemple
l'histoire de l'art ce qui ne semble pas
une chose très très facile qui fait
important avec les livres que nous avons
là vous avez relevé le défi avec brio
paraît-il bas j'ai essayé en tout cas
pascal parce que souvent c'est un
domaine qui fait un petit peu peur aux
parents mais en fait il ya beaucoup de
livres pour s'y atteler vous allez voir
il y en a des très différents le premier
s'appelle mon petit livre d'art pour
raconter la mythologie et c'est édité
aux éditions du seuil
et justement le livre s'appuie sur les
héros et les dieux mythologiques sociaux
de raconter et ouais voilà tac pour
raconter justement l'art et l'histoire
de là puisque grâce à eux et bien on va
découvrir beaucoup d'artistes différents
alors h il va par exemple permettre de
découvrir batié polo ou taisez va
permettre de découvrir picasso alors
c'est accessible à partir de 6 ans parce
qu'il ya des petites questions tout en
bas voilà pour un joujou évident mais
écoutez il faut aussi découvrir un art
devenu un voile alors il ya des petites
questions en bas de page pour inciter
les enfants justement à regarder plus en
détails d'oeuvres d'art parce que c'est
pas évident pour un enfant de se
consacre ce concentrer sur une annonce
ne peut pas comprendre voilà l'histoire
est de
du héros est très bien fait c'est très
simple vraiment je vous le conseille
c'est un très beau livre parce que mes
camarades de gens des enfants là oui les
petits enfants et plus on a de plus en
un joli en âge de liens seraient plus
d'accord mais vous leur avez appris
quand même oui l'histoire au travers des
ouvrages moi c'est l'histoire de l'art
dont nous parlons ce matin l'histoire du
giro donc je pense qu'il y en a certains
que vous ne connaissez pas non plus
puisque j'en ai découvert un certain
nombre et dans un autre site vous avez
autre chose je crie alors ici j'ai un
autre livre consacré à deux gars qui est
pas forcément le plus connu des
impressionnistes mais alors dans ce
livre là ce que voit deux gars de
samantha friedman et christina pierre au
plan qui est aux éditions albin michel
jeunesse oui on découvre en fait le pari
du 19e siècle et ce qui a incité deux
gars finalement à sortir de son atelier
parce qu'au départ il faisait de la
peinture historique en fait comme tous
les impressionnistes et il s'est dit oh
là là mais mais ce pari change alors
pourquoi ne pas sortir de l'atelier
pourquoi ne pas aller peindre les
repasseuses les chapeliers et puis
évidemment les danseuses de l'opéra
alors dans ce livre là on voit les
jolies illustrations de samantha
friedman que vous voyez ici et le joli
livre de christina bien au plan comme je
le disais on voit aussi les belles
alors je sais pas si vous allez le voir
les jolies de tableau de degas donc le
livre joue avec ça et ça permet de faire
un livre accessible à partir de 6 ans
voilà aucun livre complètement différent
a parlé de mythologie de degas l'instant
avec impressionnistes cette fois c'est
pour les plus grands peut-être à partir
de 9 ans oui plutôt à partir de 9 ans et
là on est vraiment dans le dur dans
l'histoire de là mais on va dire sans
être rébarbatif
ça vous permet de découvrir
chronologiquement les artistes donc
celui ci c'est l'histoire de l'art en bd
de la renaissance à l'époque moderne et
ça a été fait par une spécialiste
d'histoire de l'art marion augustin et
par bruno heitz au dessin c'est édité
par casterman y en a plusieurs rôles
tome est donc on découvre une famille
qui part en vacances en italie et ça
permet de remonter le temps en fait de
léonard de vinci jusqu'à louise
bourgeois est donc les peintures sont
reproduites en dessin donc c'est aussi
un petit jeu
pour ceux qui s'y connaissent déjà
retrouvé l'odeur le peintre voilà c'est
très sympa puis c'est bourré d'anecdotes
vraiment je vous le conseille c'est pour
les enfants mais aussi pour les adultes
je pense que ça vous plairait pas légal
donc papa et maman peuvent s'essayer à
ces pressions pour toute la famille à
l'issue d'un dernier clin d'oeil parce
que c'est nos dijonnais quand même les
éditions faton public quand même ce
magazine
ohlala chaque mois c'est à partir de 4
ans et pour l'histoire de l'art il ya
quand même pas mieux hein c'est un
mensuel donc vraiment avec à la une van
gogh le peintre évidemment ça a dit
d'ailleurs on les avait reçus les
éditions faton on est super fiers parce
que ça marche très très fort pour la
jeunesse et s'est fait chez nous je me
plaît à le dire souvent c'est pas s'est
pas fait à l'autre bout de la planète
voilà donc on est super fiers d'aider
fierté locale merci tiphaine